one of the questions i've been asked  quite repeatedly on the last tour is how  do i find the person who's right for me  on  social media dating platforms or just in  the general world i don't know how to  answer that question how do you find the  person that's right for you but i can  say  generically that's not a good question  it's the wrong question and if you pose  the question like that you will not find  an answer the right question is how can  i make myself into the most attractive  possible mate with young men  a huge part of the answer to that is  clean up your room put your life in  order make your bed start there at least  what you're aiming at is highly  productive  generosity  with some  spine